the trend right now and on TV with TV
musicals has been to do them live and I
like that we're kind of going against
that trend Rocky Horror won't be live on
your TV Thursday but they will be
bringing you the perfect reimagining of
the cult classic hello
but what we're most excited about the
music some of the racers have been
tweaked a little bit but it's still very
much the original vibe
so you revamp that you've modernized it
a little bit I heard yes you know though
I mean like it's still the same music it
still lives in the same plane but the
music was just so good it's still shaky
you don't mess with it too much because
it already is great this cast has some
pretty big shoes to fill
Adam is taking on Meatloaf's Eddie
Adam Lambert's one of the best male
singers in the world at the moment so
terror and Laverne Cox who's reprising
Tim Curry's frank-n-furter has also
gotten a stamp of approval have you had
a chance to talk to Tim I think you've
any advice Tim is very he guys I
wouldn't say he's given me advice he's
just given me encouragement
what a guy Tim not only plays the
criminologist in this version he was
also a fixture at rehearsals I had to
think every song from the show in front
of him like literally we were all
sitting around a piano and Tim Curry was
there and okay let's edit this tweet
transits in anyway um you have to like
watch this